the level of discussion on the David
Pakman show reddit lately has been very
very high and I mean a lot high to quote
our president join the discussion at
david pakman.com slash reddit a user
named JP din Z's posted a very
interesting comparison of the policies
of Bernie Sanders Joe Biden and Donald
Trump to try to make clear that there is
really not very much in common between
Biden and Trump and quite a bit in
common between Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders and I think it's important for
us to understand I mean listen I don't
think it's useful to pretend that Joe
Biden is something he isn't and that
applies to both sides Joe Biden is not
Bernie Sanders Joe Biden is not a
progressive Joe Biden is not going to
push for nearly every policy that Bernie
Sanders was pushing for but Joe Biden is
way closer to Bernie than he is to
Donald Trump and whether you look at the
minimum wage paid family leave Citizens
United
the death penalty prison sentencing
related to drugs abortion rights capital
gains taxes wealth taxes the climate
nuclear power you actually see that
Bernie and Trump are both knows sort of
and Biden is a yes so in any case that's
not bragging about Biden's position but
the point is if we say Biden's more like
Trump than Bernie we are just very very
wrong I want people deciding on the
facts if you think that we are better
off with Trump than Biden then vote that
way but don't be tricked into making a
move that helps Trump because you
incorrectly believe that Biden and Trump
share significant policy when really the
the vast majority of the shared policy
is between Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders
to different degrees on many issues
decide however you want but I want you
to decide with the facts not with
incorrect talking points so a very good
post by JP Dizzy's Elbon Zano posted is
David overusing the word weaponized and
a lot of people
in the responses saying this seems like
a weird thing to be concerned about and
it's an appropriate word to be using
yeah my my use of the word weaponized
has definitely increased lately because
we're seeing so much weaponization by
the the government Donald Trump has
weapon weaponized disinformation
Donald Trump has weaponized his
delusions of grandeur
Donald Trump has weaponized his own and
his followers ignorant and gullibility
we are seeing a level of weaponization
both by Donald Trump and by right-wing
media that carries water for him that is
like nothing I've ever seen and I was
actually watching I went on YouTube and
I found some clips of fox news covering
george w bush's presidency and of course
you know it's the normal playbook how do
you support a standard republican
president if you are standard right-wing
media and it almost seemed quaint
compared to the degree of weaponization
that we are seeing today it's not a
defense of george w bush and it's not a
defense of Fox News it is merely a
shocking realization I came to of how
far things have slid since the george w
bush fox news era - the trump fox news o
a n phase in which we now find ourselves
lastly user turkey bacon and cheese
posted to the reddit pedro call
appreciation writing i just want to say
that the pedro part of the show was
hilarious a nice change in mood and
worth the time he wasted banks for the
laugh yeah i actually i got an email
from someone claiming to be pedro over
the weekend with what they claimed was a
picture of them and it was just a
drawing of a completely stereotypical
Mexican man and it struck me as
incredibly offensive to some degree and
also hilarious because Pedro claims to
be Colombian but the drawing was of what
you would see as a stereotypical Mexican
like mariachi guy it's crazy the entire
Pedro Arc is taking on a life of its own
but I'm glad people are getting some
enjoyment out of it in these otherwise
very dark times
join the discussion at david pakman.com
slash read it
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blinka
stinketh lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video